M: I'm deep in the cave... Woahhh what is that?
M: Oh, I'm outside, okay, nevermind, that's, that's the sky.  That's what they call: "The Sky".
M: I thought-  W: Whoa  M: I thought that was like the roof of uh-
W: What are those fluffy things?  Those big yellow balls?  M: Shut up, shut up.
W: Geez, why'd you have to go so far?
M: Eh, cause I'm a baller, I'm a shot caller.  W: Oh, I see you!  M: Yeah, do you?  W: Yeah.
M: Kay, this is copper ore, but we need aluminum ore.  W: How can you tell?  M: You might as well get this stuff.
M: Ah, ah, ah!  I fell!  I fell!  I'm not dead, thankfully.  Okay, I'm fine, I'm fine.
M: I know you're worried about me but I'm fine
W: Noooo
Shit, I ju--I clicked out of the game again
M: Just stop doing that
M: Okay I'm not quite brave enough to go jumpin' down there just yet, ooh what are you?
M: What in the hell are you?
M: I don't know what this is but it's big bulbous and goopy I don't wanna get near it
W: Duuude touch it~
M: ....no
W: suck it
M: Id rather not...
W: *laughs*
W: Thats the point of the game!
W: You taught me~
M: Yea, okay but you gotta conservative about your sucking
M: You can't- awh! Found it! Found aluminum ore.
M: Got it, got it, got it, cool, cool, cool.
M: I might die down here but..
W: Aw well your defiantly going to die.    M: avenge me-
W: But just come closer and I'll pick up your body...
M: Okaay~ alright then...
W: I have um...five slots full of uh...
W:...copper.
M: Well good for you..
W: I could get more cause- *burp* ooooh god... There's some over there.
M: Ah! The demons! *laughs* The demons!
W: There coming out of me!
M: Alright, hang on. I got--I might be able to get one more stack. W: Im too far away to suck.
M: Nothings to far to sack...secks..suck... suck if you belieeve. W: You're actually right cause I started sucking it.
M: Ok ive got three stacks of aluminum ore, im gonna try to make my way back.
M: Cause if I die, thats gonna be heart breaking...or whatever...youll be so sad. YOU'D MISS ME RIGHT?! ...Youd miss me.
W: Oh yeah, eh, my fearless leader.
M: Thb-pfft
M: Pfft
M: pfft
M: pfft    W: When can I suck and not suck?!
W:It won't let me suck something- afehfeh somethings but then other things it, will
M:It's such- W:It's so difficult to no what to suck
M:Such is the mysteries of the way of the suck
W:That's true M:You need to, you need to be stronger of mind
W:See I'm not a, a I M:And of suck
W:I don't know to much about the suckage ways
M:You've never read Sucksu's Suck of War?
W:*hehe* Sucksu's
M:You never read that? No?
W:I can't say I have, can you lend it to me?
M:I ah *hehe* I'll give you an esteemed copy from the very- from the congressional library.
M:It's a, it's a rare first edition.
M:Slightly moist around the edges *laughs*
W:*more laughs*
M:The pages are kinda stuck together *laughs* a little bit
*more laughs*
M:Yeah. But it's, it's, it's really, it's really uh uh a delightful, delightful read.
M:You should, you should pick it up sometime.
W:Uh I, I think I will.
M:Wait are you back at, are you back at the base?
W:yes I'm most certainly, yeah. M:omg when did you get back to the base I thought we had an invader in our system!
M:like someone, like someone in dark souls just came in to fuck up our day W:Can you do that?
M:No you cant do that
W:Awww man I was gonna say likes go screw somebody
M:oh yeah lets go screw somebody That sounds great!!!
W:Hey I'm learning to suck and blow
W:Now I've got to learn how to screw.
See look, that was all